Hello.
This is Acton flat guestroom number 21.1.
It's April 21st 2022.
And we're here with Shannon.
Proksch and Jen will be giving a talk.
Coordination
dynamics of Multi-Agent Interaction.
The talk will happen
for maybe around an hour
and then there'll be time for Q&A.
So feel free to ask any questions
in the chat during.
So off to you, Shannon.
Looking forward to this talk and thanks
again for joining on active flight.
So thanks so much.
So I'm Shannon Daniels, already
giving you the title of our talk.
And I'm coming to you from the University
of California in Racette,
where I'm a Ph.D.
candidate, and I'll actually
be defending this summer.
So maybe the next time you hear from me,
I'll be talking to you
from Augustana University,
where I will be starting a tenured
professor position later this fall.
As an assistant professor
of psychology and neuroscience
Oh, nice, nice.
Thanks.
So that's that I'm not going
to talk to you about neuroscience today.
I'm going to talk to you a little bit
about the behavior of crowds.
And I stole this roadmap idea from
previous active inference lab sessions.
And this is kind of outlining
where we'll be going today.
So first,
the first thing we're going to do
is really dig into a little bit of theory
and data
I'm going to give a bit of a brief
introduction to multi-agent interaction
and what kind of human behavior
I'm interested in.
And I'm going to walk
through a couple of ways that
active inference
folks might be interested
in crowd dynamics and behavior,
but primarily I'm going to be focusing
on dynamical systems theory
and the notion of synergies and the tools
that come along with these concepts.
And then finally, I'm going to show you
a model system where we apply these tools
to a system of couple of metronomes.
Before I look at some empirical data
from real, real world interaction,
musical performance, and also of crowds
cheering at a basketball game.
So first,
what is multi-agent interaction?
This is simply an interaction that's
happening between two or more agents.
In our case, we're looking at people
and each of these people,
they'll have their own personal goals
and behaviors,
but their individual behaviors
are influenced in some way
by interacting with other agents
in their shared environment.
And I want to talk about two forms
of multi-agent coordination today
and the best way to introduce this is
through a short thought experiment. So
I'll just have
you imagine
the sounds of a crowded coffee shop.
Consider how individuals
in that coffee shop
might be interacting with each other.
There might be some small groups,
there might be pairs,
but mostly it's many individuals
engaging in small temporary interactions.
And these individuals aren't coordinating
with every other individual
in some sort of cohesive coffee shop
group.
They're just a jumble of individual
individuals
who are cohabiting, a shared space.
Now, instead, imagine the audience
on the floor of a rock concert.
They're cheering or singing
along with the artists on the stage.
And alternatively, imagine the fan
section at your favorite sporting event
emerging into a synchronous chant
or a chorus of resounding boos.
Imagine how individuals in these large
crowds might be interacting
with each other as they cheer, sing,
chant or boo.
They're all sharing in similar behavioral
states engaging in similar actions.
They're likely sharing similar
physiological states like breathing rates
and neural states as well.
These crowds are tuning together in time.
They're behaving and they're coordinating
like one large interdependent group,
and you could refer to these
as shared acoustic spaces.
And they include
various levels of interaction
from dyads pairs of individuals
or larger and larger groups.
And I might even call
these acoustic social worlds
the acoustic signal
that's generated by these crowds.
It carries some information
about their behavioral dynamics
that were employed
in creating that signal.
And the sounds these crowd makes carry
some sort of information
about the status of that crowd,
either as an
incidental collection
of lots of individual coffee goers
or an integrated and coordinated
crowd like a crowd of concert goers.
And there are, of course,
many and important factors at play
when we're evaluating these acoustics
social worlds, and we're trying to decide
whether that crowd is acting
as one integrated multi-agent system
rather than a collection
of independent agents.
And these include the social context.
A coffee shop is different than a concert
arena,
the development
of patterned cultural practices
in these different contexts and different
scripts surrounding what events happen
and when these events happen
and different regimes of shared attention
between each of these agents.
And these are things
you've talked about in the inference lab
before.
And basically this is all a rather long
winded way of saying that we expect
coffee shop behavior in a coffee shop
and concert behavior in a concert arena.
If I were going to talk to you
in the language of Act of Inference,
I might talk to you today
about Markov blankets
and we might talk
about the statistical boundary
that might be behind
a pair of interacting
individuals
around a pair of interacting individuals
separating their internal states
of this interaction.
With the rest of the interactions
happening in a coffee shop crowd.
And I might talk about
how the statistical boundary expands
as we start to engage or interact
with larger groups of people
from three to four to
maybe 100 people were more.
We're in a large group interaction,
and while this can be a really useful way
to model multi-agent interaction,
to talk about a suite of nested markup
blankets, we quickly run into questions
of how a researcher chooses
where to draw a Markov blanket
at any given system
or where to draw each nested Markov
blanket
in a given system.
And this is the topic that you've discussed a lot in the Active Inference Lab.
You spent
some time talking with you,
Bernard Berg and colleagues
after the recent BBC article commentaries
and how there might be differences
from me as a researcher
applying some sort of Markov
blanket around a system versus
the actual agents
interacting in that system.
But I just mentioned this idea of March
markup blankets to situate the topic
for the audience of these
into active inference lab live streams.
As far as measuring
the emergence
of an integrated interacting crowd,
this is an empirical question
that I'm asking rather
than a modeling question,
and I'm not a mathematician or a modeler.
So for this question
about groups of interacting people,
I found empirical tools
from dynamical systems
theory and with the concept
of interpersonal synergies.
So that's one
I'm going to introduce to you guys next.
So Dynamical Systems Theory,
this considers a trajectory of behavior
of a system over time,
and the concept of synergies arises
from the field of motor control
as a solution
to the degrees of freedom problem.
So essentially the degrees
of freedom problem is that fine
and precise control of every degree
of freedom in a motor movement
would be computationally intractable
for the nervous system to solve.
And what you see
here is a minor hammering
and you see these light patterns.
This is really sort of the earliest sort
of motion capture that we had.
And we're seeing the trajectory
of his arm hammering here.
And you can see that
even though the hammer
is hitting the same place every time,
you'll have to trust me,
that's hitting the same place every time.
His arm is taking a slightly different
trajectory to get there.
But it generally covers
this one spring behavior,
and that's
because the muscles in his arm
here are self-organizing and two coupled
and locally constrained
degrees of freedom forming temporary
soft assemblies of motor function
that's enabling this flexible movement
and coordination here.
But another way, synergies are identified
by their functional specificity,
specificity, dimensional compression
and reciprocal compensation
what are those?
Well, the need to perform
a specific function like hammering
that and build
that functional specificity temporarily
shapes the coordination
of several components into one system
that's dimensional compression
in which external
and internal perturbations
are flexibly dealt with via compensatory
adjustments of the components,
reciprocal compensation.
So each muscle in his arm is compensating
for the activity of the other muscle.
And if he was bumped slightly,
there would be compensation
from other muscles
to ensure that handle hits its location
and this
is all done
in order to preserve the functionality
of the whole system
for as long as it's needed.
And that last comment,
for as long as it's needed,
that gets the notion of softness smoothly
where any of these units
in this picture here
might be functionally coupled
just for as long
as you need to perform that task.
So if we're talking about
a group of people,
this this group of people might form
some sort of complex system
just while they're interacting
for that meeting,
while they're at that concert,
until they disperse
and they're ready to move on
we can differentiate
mere coordination,
which might happen between two people
as a result of engaging
with the same stimulus
and similar patterns of actions
from a true interpersonal synergy.
And you see here we might see
the same patterns of movement.
If we have two individuals who are maybe
just listening to the same set of music.
But if these individuals are interacting
with each other
where the action of one person
and the action of the second person
is constraining each other, then this is
where an interpersonal synergy happens.
And these
synergies are the result of these
micro scale structures of a system
giving rise to macro scale dynamics.
When a synergy develops,
we no longer need to describe
the independent dynamics
of each micro-scale structure.
We can instead describe the behavior
of this single interaction
dominant system,
which consists of complementary actions
from each person's motor activity
as it pertains to their role in this
softly, simple and complex system.
And you might even notice
some similarities here between
these graphics and a graphic
we might draw of nested Markov blankets.
And these might very well
be two sides of the same coin,
just two perspectives
with a very similar conceptual
landscape here.
And there's a variety of methods
for studying the coordination dynamics
that underlie interpersonal coordination.
For example,
we might ask two people to sit next
to each other and swing pendulums or two
rocking, rocking chairs,
and we can measure how these individuals,
intentionally or unintentionally
synchronize their behavior
as each
individual's action becomes
coupled to their partner.
Or we can ask musicians to play together
in a musical ensemble or a duet,
and we can measure
how these quartets of duets move together
in time, forming these loosely
coupled interpersonal synergies
but in each of these interactions,
a motor or acoustic behavioral output
of each interacting individual
was measured and analyzed for meaningful
correlations between these individuals.
So importantly in these experiments
here, it has been possible to obtain
these measurements of individual behavior
in order to correlate the behavior
of these individuals and examine
the emergent coordination dynamics
of multi-age interaction
and social self-organization.
But what happens
when we have this massive
crowd of people,
we measure the interpersonal synergies
that form in such a large crowd.
How does a group of people move
between novel and habitual
patterns of coordination?
How does a multi-agent system navigate
transitions between chaos and stability?
And let's make it a little bit trickier.
The real world is messy in measurement.
It's difficult in a naturalistic social
interaction, in a very large crowd.
I probably can't measure the behavior
of every single individual person.
I probably can't give everyone
an individual microphone.
I probably can't track each person's
individual brain states,
and I might not even have access
to a camera, let alone a set of motion
capture cameras and hundreds of markers
to track everyone's head and movements
so let's come back to the crowds
we imagined
at the start of this discussion
when you were imagining this coffeeshop
crowd and the crowd at the rock concert.
You might have also been imagining how
these concerts, how these crowds sounded.
So the difference between
this disjointed
noise you might hear at the coffee shop
and this all together coordinated singing
maybe in a rock concert,
it's trivial, trivially easy for you
or I to identify
an uncoordinated group of independent
individuals
happening to coexist in a shared space
versus a coordinated group
of interdependent group members
in a crowd.
We can simply hear that these two groups
of people sound different.
Similarly, we can simply hear
when we ourselves are engaged
and participating as a collective
sort of agent while we're interacting
with a large group of people
or in a very large musical ensemble.
So I'm taking that idea
and I think we can measure
the sounds of the crowd mics,
and with so well placed microphone
or a few microphones,
we can generate a single audio
recording of the sound setting
interacting group makes over time.
And I know
that a human can make inferences
about the interactions
and the acoustics of the world of a crowd
just by listening
so similarly,
I want to know if this Dynamical Systems
toolkit that I have in allow us
to make inferences about the behavior
of an entire complex system
based on this one acoustic measurement
that we have access to.
So for the next little while, I'm
going to walk through a bit of theory,
and then it's for example,
until I eventually end this talk
with data from real live
multi-agent groups that we're analyzing
with tools from dynamical systems theory
so one of our most
simple complex dynamical systems
is a metronome or a pendulum.
So Christopher Regan's first discovered
this activity of two pendulums
from four pendulum clocks will be related
to each other when these clocks
are hanging from a shared surface.
And what he found
was that these pendulums would swing
and anti synchrony with each other
and since then, in 1600s or so,
there's been
lots of research on pendulums
and on a couple of metronomes.
And if we put
these metronomes at time
keeping device for, for making music
on a shared platform, and maybe that
platform rotates like this,
you'll see each of these metronomes
come into synchrony with each other.
These are just static pictures.
So to really help you visualize this
and hear this,
I'm recording a little bit of help
from the Mythbusters
the Mythbusters on YouTube.
So hopefully it is free
and I'm copyrighted
and I'm just going to skip ahead here to
partway into the episode.
Friction and momentum
as I can so that only the metronome
is having the effect.
Now, let's try to.
Adam doubles his trouble with
two metronomes set to the same tick Mark.
Look at that movement on this platform.
And after 2 minutes,
the shimmy takes over.
Stay with it, boys.
Nice.
It's totally working.
It just took them a little while
to find each other's rhythm.
To have an idea.
I stop the platform.
They should drop out of phase
there it is.
The moving platform is totally,
totally critical to this experiment.
So all right, so that's
Adam Savage there with Two Metronomes,
one on Earth.
Why does this matter? A mile?
What he's done is replicated that
findings of that centuries old experiment
that was originally conducted
with pendulums on a clock.
And he noted that
this moving platform here is
what's totally, totally critical.
But what I want you to also think of
is that you heard these
metronomes slowly
coming into phase with each other.
They were becoming interdependent
on each other's behavior because they are
connected by this coupling mechanism
here, this the shared platform.
And as Adam correctly notes, this moving
platform is totally, totally critical.
And in fact, when you saw him
stop the platform, the metronomes were no
longer coupled and their behavior
no longer affects the other
this platform here.
It can take many forms
as long as it is freely flowing and
responsive to the Metronomes movement.
And for the Metronomes, this platform
is the essential coupling mechanism
for this emergent of coordinated
acoustic behavior in humans.
This coordination doesn't
have to be a physical platform.
In fact,
I argue that it is the interaction itself
which serves as a coupling mechanism
for multi-agent human behavior.
And we're going
to spend just a little bit more time
with metronomes before
I get on to real human groups here.
So when you have many metronomes
on a shared platform,
you can have more than two.
They're going to transition
from uncoordinated random things
to coordinated synchronicity
is what you're going to hear next
is the acoustic output of 32 metronomes
on a freely moving platform.
And I'm going to justify
to you two things
that we can identify I emergent
coordinated behaviors in acoustic data
and what all I'm going
to justify what state space
reconstruction is and how this tool
from dynamical systems can help us
to analyze that acoustic data.
So I'm going to start at the beginning
with each of the metronomes and
random things
and this really takes a bit of a time
so we don't have to listen to that
for so long.
I'm going to skip ahead
so what you heard was 32 metronomes
all ticking at their own tempo,
at their natural period.
It sounded like a bunch of random noise.
But this platform again
served as a coupling mechanism,
and synchronization
between the metronomes emerged
so they began to sound like one group
sticking together.
And this is an example of
the type of data will be investigating
for the emergence of coordination
and acoustic signals.
So keep these metronomes in mind.
Don't don't play the metronomes again.
The platform is serving
as a coupling mechanism.
A synchronization emerges.
They begin to sound like one group
so we're going to visit some theory.
I'm going to introduce you to tachyons
theorem and phase space reconstruction.
So if we
take one time series from a system,
this is the Lorenz system here.
It's defined
by a set of three differential equations.
But what you need to know
is that we can construct the behavior
of this system as a whole by measuring
only one of its parts.
This is accomplished by embedding
delayed copies of a single time
series
into multiple dimensions on some delay.
So here's
one of this time
series extracted from the word system.
And we delay that time series to make
another time series delay once more.
To make a third time series,
we take these three dimensions,
and we use them to reconstruct
a projection of the Lawrence system.
And this is Face Space Reconstruction,
and you can see that
it maintains the topography
or the same shape
as the original Lawrence system.
In the case of our acoustic data,
I'm going to take a time series
of that sound, that acoustic signal
and I'm going to follow these steps here.
So I'm going to follow these steps here
to reconstruct the behavior
of those metronomes over time.
And once we've completed the space
based reconstruction,
I'm going to visualize the behavior
of our reconstructed system
by generating what we call
recurrence plot.
This is done by plotting recurrent points
from the reconstructed base space
within some radius that we set.
And we can evaluate the structures
in these recurrence plots
using recurrence quantification analysis.
So on the right here, you're seeing
a few examples of different time series,
and you're seeing their reconstructed
face base here
and on the bottom
you're seeing the recurrence plot that we
generate from these reconstructed faces.
So one of the simplest measures
that we can glean
from recurrence
plot is the rate that states recur.
And this is called recurrence rate
and on the left
here we're seeing a time series
of a simple sine wave.
And when we reconstruct it,
we end up seeing something
a bit like an oval or a circle.
And when we plot a point
on our recurrent system every time
or recurrence,
but here, every time our system revisits
a space on the circle here
so in the sideways recurrence plot,
we're seeing these diagonal lines,
these diagonal lines are reflecting
deterministic behavior.
And they track how similar system,
similar sequences of values
change over time.
So this sign right here,
it's reliably deterministic.
If it starts here, it's going to go here
next, then it's going to go there next.
And that gives us
these long recurrence values here.
And as you probably expect,
this measure is called determinism.
In the
middle, we see uncorrelated white noise.
And you can see this signal already looks
much more random than our sine wave.
And when we reconstruct it in face space,
I don't really see
a shape here that we can get much out of.
And underneath you see our recurrence
plot and it looks similarly random.
You could think of it like white noise
on your television, even
finally on the right, we see it time
series extracted from speech.
It's a little bit deterministic,
like our sine wave
if it goes up, it's going to come down,
but it's also drifting a bit.
And you can see if we reconstruct
that face space
instead of a simple oval we're seeing.
Yep, we're seeing a sort of transient
signal here and in the recurrence spot,
we're also going to be seeing
for variation lengths in these diagonals.
And finally, recurrence spots
can contain these vertical structures
that you don't see here.
In addition to diagonals.
And these are indications
of periods of stability.
We measure these as the value
preliminary and liminality.
You can contrast it with determinism
and measures how a signal is organized
in terms of simple,
similar absolute values
that are stable over time.
And this is one representation
of recurrent spots.
It takes a little bit of time
to get comfortable with what
a current spot it is.
So I just have a different visualization
to show you
a little bit of the same thing.
So these are the same set of IQ measures
that we take from our system
and plot on recurrence, but
this is demonstrating recurrence rate.
It's just the percentage
of recurrent points
that we see
on this recurrent plot over time.
And it represents patterns of behavior
that repeat over time
determinism,
and it's the percentage of points that
fall in a diagonal at any time,
and it represents behaviors
that belongs to a longer sequence
of behavior, entropy.
This is the variability in lengths
of these diagonal lines down here,
and it represents the amount of disorder
that there might be in these sequences.
Finally, Liminality,
here are the percentage of points
that fall on a vertical line.
And this represents clusters of behavior
that might repeat for a length of time,
like when a system revisits
a period of behavior,
leaves
and returns that behavioral state again.
All right.
So it's a lot of theory.
I need to bring you back to the metronome
so we know what's going on here.
So what you see here, this is a picture
of our uncoordinated metronomes.
They're moving
and all sorts of directions.
And finally,
our coordinated metronomes at the bottom.
And I took 32nd a 32nd
acoustic signal from each
each, a set of behaviors here.
And on the right, I have signals
from this uncoordinated metronome
and the recurrent support
we generated from them
and you can see this first recurrence,
but it resembles
that kind of uncorrelated white noise.
I don't see a lot of structure here.
And then in our time series
for the coordinated Metronomes,
you start to see some periodicity
kind of in the signal here,
and you see a lot more of these laminar
structures down here in the bottom.
These vertical structures which indicate
these periods of stable states
in this group, metronome behavior,
I could break that down even smaller
and I could look at 5 seconds of sound
and we see the same structures emerging.
You can also see a bit
more clearly these spikes that occur
in that coordinated metronomes
that correlate with these vertical
structures than we did in the last one.
So this is great.
Now you're experts.
You've learned
everything you need to know to evaluate
the emergence of coordination.
When we measure it
from a global acoustic signal
and you know, how to visualize
that inner occurrence plot
and how to interpret that plot.
So we're going to apply all of this
human data.
And I want to remember for the Metronomes
this platform is the essential
coupling mechanism for the emergence
of coordinated behavior for humans.
The interaction is totally,
totally critical
so if, say, me and my colleague
Mark Reeves from the Applied Mathematics
Department here, you see more sudden.
So we don't need a shared platform.
Instead we just need to interact
with other human beings
in order to couple
our multi-agent human behavior
so now that
we've got this far,
I promise you some empirical data
and I'm going to tell you
about multi-agent interaction.
First in a specific musical ensemble
performing a specific musical work
and then in the crowd
at a basketball game.
So first our musical ensemble here
they're performing a work called
Welcome to the Imagination World
by Tsuki Shimizu
and this group of musician,
they're performing
this piece that was composed
to do something interesting.
So the composer wrote
the first few minutes of this
musical piece to be completely random
and music theory terms,
we call this Aleatoric it's
when some element of the music
is left up to chance
or to whatever the performers
decide to play in that moment.
So the start of this piece
sounds a little bit like this
OK, that flute gets a little loud for me.
So this is not the musicians
warming up on stage.
This is the actual music.
The musicians themselves are instructed
not to interact with each other.
And you can see
this is kind of hard for musicians
because you do hear musicians
sort of taking turns
starting each musical line a little bit
and it's a little bit
hard to play completely random.
You hear some folks playing
scales up and down, but in general,
this is supposed to sound random and
they're not supposed to be coordinated.
And after a few minutes,
the musical score
actually directs the musicians
to begin coordinating with each other.
And then this happens.
I'll show you what that sounds like.
And then
you I'm going
to stop it right before it gets exciting.
So once you begin coordinating
with each other,
they begin to sound like one
interacting musical ensemble.
So this musical interaction is serving
as the coupling mechanism
and the coordination
between the musicians arises,
and they begin to sound like one
interacting ensemble
now we're not seeing emergent
or spontaneous interaction
in this particular musical composition
and this performance.
Musicians are told by the musical
for precisely when to begin
coordinating their actions.
And in this particular performance,
the divide between uncoordinated and
joint music making is made
even more apparent by a theatrical trick.
The lights turn on,
and then the conductor arrives on stage
just as the musicians begin
to play together as one ensemble.
But I'm using this as a model system
because I know the behavior.
They're supposed to be engaged,
and I know that there's
going to be a transition
from uncoordinated
to coordinated behavior.
So I can use that knowledge
to ask the questions.
Are there any differences in non-linear
recurrence dynamics measured by our aim
between the uncoordinated
acoustic behavior and the coordinated
behavior of this musical ensemble?
And. Well, there absolutely are.
So at the top, you're seeing the first
and last 30 seconds
of that first piece,
the first part of the performance.
On the bottom, you're seeing the first
and last 30 seconds of the second part
of the performance.
Once musicians have become coordinated
and we can see that the acoustic behavior
from these musicians in the coordinated
section of the music is more structured.
We see these bursts
of vertical lines here
with where you have
these stretches of connected
sound, connected
stretches of sound for periods of time
and again,
we can look even closer at five
second samples and we can see
the same structures in the same
vertical structures in the coordinated,
but not the uncoordinated sections.
So if I take just
these little blocks here,
zoom in
to 5 seconds,
we see a little bit more structure here
and a little bit less there, a little bit
noisier structure here.
These are just four visualizations.
This is not actually the five second
snippet here,
but it works for getting the idea across.
OK, so cool.
I see these structures
in their current spot,
but is it really more structured
when musicians are coordinated?
We can do some statistics
and we can visualize our data
in another way.
So these are distributions
of all of those measures that we
extracted from their current spot.
And you can see coordinated sections
in blue, uncoordinated sections and red
and we're seeing that when the musicians
begin interacting with each other
as a coordinated musical ensemble,
recurrence
and stability measures increase overall.
So we have higher also more variable
our measures
when they're coordinated
and we see lower and less variable
criteria measures
when they're uncoordinated
and we
can see this even a little more clearly
if we can plot
those same measures over time
and the blue
and purple lines here are representing
uncoordinated section of the piece.
Orange and green is represented
sorry, blue and purple is coordinated.
Orange and green is uncoordinated.
And we can see that over time
when the musicians are coordinated
and acting like one interacting ensemble,
they're able to explore a greater variety
of recurrent singing mix.
They're able to explore more behavioral
states than when they're uncoordinated.
And we see all of these measures,
no matter what,
they are hovering around
a small subset of dynamics.
Now, you would be forgiven
if you are skeptical of these results.
After all, the entire musical performance
is over 8 minutes long.
Maybe I simply chose
the most uncoordinated sections
and the most uncoordinated
sections of the song,
and you'd be smart to have this worry.
Our peer reviewers shared the same worry,
so we graphed
the time series of our three metrics
for the entire piece,
and it's pretty clear
even if you don't know
what these values are,
that there's some difference
in all of these hot
pink and blue kind of graphs and these
bottom orange and green type of graphs
we're seeing this same greater
variability,
greater values and more variability
in each of these are three metrics.
When the musicians are coordinated,
then when they're performing
as a bunch of individuals on stage.
And the takeaway here
is that these musicians,
when they're interacting together
as a musical ensemble,
they're able to explore a greater variety
of acoustic behavior when they're
when they've formed a single complex
system and interpersonal synergy,
then when they were acting
as a lot of individuals on stage
and we were able to use these non-linear
statistical methods
from dynamical system
theory to measure that change
cool.
So that's a musical ensemble.
I'm using it as a model.
So some mix,
we know what the behavior should be,
and I measure this
from a different kind of system,
one that doesn't have a script
dictating the behavior
of what's going on on the stage.
So to do that, I look at data recorded
from the student section
of a BYU basketball game,
and this data was collected
by Butler and colleagues
and labeled by many hard
working undergraduate students.
And we have basically recordings
from the crowd that are labeled based on
what kind of crowd sounds
they're making, whether they're cheering.
This is like a loud, positive
crowd vocalization vocalization
and whether they're applauding.
So this is mostly clapping.
That could include some vocalization,
distraction, noise
when you're trying to distract
someone from a free throw, mainly
positive chants.
So this is the fans chanting their
their BYU Cougars chants or defense
native chanting.
It's when they're angry
rather than cheering, positively singing,
and then silence
so we're taking this data
and we're going to ask a similar question
so we don't have a clear transition from
uncoordinated to coordinated behavior.
But we do have all of these
different types of behavior.
So we're going to ask,
is there a relationship
between nonlinear recurrence dynamics
measured by our cue
and these different categories
of acoustic behavior at the crowd?
At this basketball game,
we follow the same process.
We extract acoustic signals
and we cut them up into
five second samples here,
and we use these signals to generate
recurrent thoughts.
And we take the measures
from that recurrent spot
to see if there's anything different.
And I'm going to show
you just to recurrence.
But in the next slide, I'm
going to show you a quote from positive
chanting and from distraction noise
so here's distraction noise.
It looks like right noise.
It looks like what you would see
on your television screen.
And when I show you positive chant,
there's clearly a striking difference.
There's almost
no structure and distraction noise here,
but there are very clear
laminar bursts of activity
represented in these vertical lines.
And in fact, these two plots
look very similar to our unsynchronized
and synchronized metronome was way back
from the middle of this talk.
And intuitively, this makes sense.
If you're trying to distract
someone during a free throw,
you're making all sorts of random sounds.
You might be shaking your keys around.
People are stomping on the stands, but
if you're cheering your team on, trying
to motivate them to score more points,
or if you're mounting a strong defense,
you're going to be working
together, shouting
whatever your chant is, go team,
go defense.
And it's going to occur
in a very rhythmic, metronomic fashion.
And we
can compare
how all of these distributions
of our human metrics look between each
different kind of crowd noise.
And you can see there's
quite a lot of overlap but
there's also some difference.
So positive and negative chants
seem to be a bit similar to each other
in every category, which makes sense
because whether they're chanting
in a positive or negative energy,
it's still this rhythmic,
I socratous behavior that's happening
distraction, noise, cheers and applause.
On the other hand,
all seem pretty similar to each other,
no matter where we look at them.
And then finally,
all the way on the lowest
scale is angry noise here.
And one thing to note is
we had very,
very few samples of angry noise here.
So that could be why
we're seeing a few of these differences.
And if we had more samples,
maybe angry noise would look a bit
more like distraction noise.
So visually,
we can see there are differences
and these are two way metrics
for all of these crowd sounds.
And we don't want to just do visuals.
So we can do some statistics here.
This is just another visualization
of our estimate of marginal means showing
pairwise comparisons
between every crowd zone category.
And it's a graphical representation
of the estimated marginal means.
If these red lines overlap,
that means there are not significant
differences between,
for instance, abstraction, noise,
cheers, and applause.
Hear positive and negative chant
do look different.
However
interesting in that angry
noise is far out by itself.
So knowing this
I mentioned very briefly earlier,
I have a colleague
in the Applied Mathematics Department,
and one thing she's interested in
is whether we can give a machine
learning algorithm.
Some of these are three
metrics to tell the difference
between these different crowd sounds.
The researchers at BYU have done this
with traditional sound metrics,
spectral analysis, cultural analysis,
and we're doing it
with our automated metrics.
So we're focused
more on the rhythmic content
rather than pitch
or spectral content of the sound.
And she
is doing this in two ways.
So one is training a neural network
with image classification.
And what I'm going to show you
if you results from is a random force
that is using these recurrent features
as input
and doing some feature vector
classification, using decision trees
and doing some stuff
that if you ask me questions about,
I will not know the answer because I'm
not the mathematician in this context.
But once you train that algorithm,
it can actually learn the differences
between these crowd sounds.
So if
these are dark blue along the diagonal,
that means that it degrades to very well.
If they're light blue,
that means there is some confusion here.
And if we remember through
one of the previous
graphs, applause, abstraction, noise,
all kind of looks similar to each other.
So if we sort of smush those into
one distraction category,
I'll put applause and cheer together
and put positive negative chants here
we get even better classification.
And this part is
something we're still working on.
Hopefully we will be ready to submit
it in a paper kind of soon.
But now that
we're
ending on this really complex point,
what have we learned
first we took a quick dove into
dynamical systems theory.